hello everyone welcome to today's
cast understanding emotional
intelligence actionable strategies to
improve your leadership performance aim
duty or Oracle efforts and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we are
delighted to bring you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by an education grant from lab
leaders lab leaders is Rochas promise to
empower laboratories and the people
within them this is accomplished by
providing clinical and strategic insight
support and solutions from the
industry's top innovators vo lab leaders
comm the 2016 lab leaders webinar series
and through L to summit our lab leaders
live events we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green - and a button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CTE button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
Calvin Dyer Calvin Dyer is a certified
coach and developed his unique frame of
reference through his military service
working on highly complex engineering
projects and as a certified financial
planner working with high net worth
families and business owners Calvin
earned a Master of Science in electrical
engineering from Wright State University
and received his formal coach training
through the Institute for professional
excellence in coaching it became a
certified coach in 2013 I will now turn
it over to Calvin Dyer for his
presentation Thank You Judy and I just
want to welcome everybody and I was
taking a look at the map and just the of
who's on the call we've got somebody and
looks like Istanbul Turkey and number of
people in Europe throughout the United
States Central America and South America
Canada so welcome and again thank you to
lab roots and broche for creating this
great platform to promote leadership in
the laboratory community and I also want
to extend a thank you to Mayo medical
laboratory for hosting me today as I go
through this this webinar and I have a
number of the lab folks from Mayo
medical lab in the room with me today
and so let's get started let's take a
journey and learn a little bit about
emotional intelligence sort of what is
it sometimes it's referred to as EQ or
II I and and so some of this is what
does EQ look like in real life and from
a business perspective why should I even
be interested in using EQ and all no
webinar is really complete unless you
really have some tools to take away so I
want to give you a couple of tools today
some things you can go right back to
your work area and your personal
professional life put them to use and
start practicing and developing your EQ
and then I'm going to give you a
challenge at the end a small 45 dollar
challenge a good stocking stuffer for
this time of year something that you can
take away and work on maybe over the
over the holidays so but before I switch
a slide and really go into this I'd like
to pose a question this is sort of a
rhetorical question I really want to get
you thinking but how ready are you how
warmed up are you to take an active part
in your own personal and professional
leadership development so think about
that for a moment we all have a set of
mental models that we use to process
information make decisions and interact
with others and some of that information
the that you'll be exposed to today is
going to change your mental model and
the things that you're exposed to and
your leadership journeys change your
mental models and what I would like you
to do is be open to those challenge and
believe me I know I was
and and throughout my leadership journey
so here we go so this gives us the first
opportunity to at least take a look at
who's on the call and give you the
ability to interact with the system a
little bit so if you're if you're by
yourself in a room you know where do you
fit in this on this scale are you an
individual contributor a frontline
manager do you manage managers or do you
have some other role in the laboratory
and for those in a conference room with
you would sort of look around the room
and give us an input on on who's there
and I just give you a few seconds to
take this poll and then we're going to
we'll close it out and look at the
results so this gives us up some
practices we had four or five more of
these interactive pieces through here
through the webinar and this just helps
us get rolling
so we're going to see the results here
in a second so we have we have a good
mix and people that have other duties in
the lab a lot of first line managers
that's good manager managers and some
individual contributors so there now you
have a sort of a opportunity to see how
this polling works and how we're going
to use it going forward so thank you for
participating and let's get rolling so
I'd like to start with a quote by by
this author Hyrum Smith and it's
whenever there's a gap between what you
value and what you are doing you are in
pain so think about that for a minute
we're really all creatures of emotions
at some point or another even the most
ardent scientists among us even as an
engineer myself and we feel that the
pole to be in sync with what we value
most in our lives and when we're out of
balance with those values like when we
don't respond to correctly to others we
make poor decisions or where we fail on
a project that causes pain and so Smith
is in his book he defines these three
gaps as the beliefs gap the values gap
and the time gap and the beliefs gap is
just the gap between what we believe in
the behaved that lead us the behaviors
that lead us to to meet our needs or the
beliefs that don't lead us to meet our
needs the values gap is the gap we've
entered is the gap between what we value
most in life and where we invest our
time and energy and the time gap is the
gap between what we plan to do each day
and we actually get done and so keep
those gaps in mind as we move through
this realm of emotional intelligence so
I'm going to start with our first model
I like models models really help provide
some context around relationships
between various concepts
and you use models in your laboratory
everyday in your everyday setting and
how you process work interpret results
or even make decisions so here is the
model that we're going to use to help us
understand emotions this model comes
from dr. robert plutchik and and so
you'll see on here that there are eight
what we'll call base emotions and then
there are the other emotions from that
so there's these bipolar pairs we'll
call them so if you look at the on the
on the chart joy and sadness are across
from each other anticipation and
surprise are across from each other
those emotions in the middle ring are
like I said the base emotions the higher
energy form of those emotions are found
at the center for example the high
energy form of anger would be rage and
from this model you can also see that
the low energy form of anger is
annoyance and those emotions that are
combinations of the base emotions are
shown between the petals so for example
the combination between joy and
anticipation would be optimism and Aven
models like this really help us create a
language to understand the gap between
where we are and where we want to be and
sometimes being in the angry state is a
good thing it's it's not the emotion
that's the bad or the emotion that
causes the problem it's the reaction or
action from the emotion and what we
display why we're in that state that
really helps us define our emotional
intelligence so here's a great example
of what emotional intelligence isn't
anybody that's watched the Big Bang
Theory on on TV at least those of us in
the United States know that that Sheldon
has extremely low emotional intelligence
and really is unaware of sort of how he
impacts other people
so here's another opportunity for us to
to interact and I'd like you two to read
the question so which part of our
communication contributes the 55% of the
message so if you would vote on your
vote between words tone of voice or body
language
this original research come from a
scientist by Navin Mehrabian
and I really I really don't want to
belittle his work but an orchid or to
put it in light context but I do want to
drive a point home here on really what
the answer to this is and as soon as we
close the poll out we'll see the body
language tone of voice and words let's
see the right answer of course is body
language now you know in today's world
and our social media we use a lot of
written words even in the laboratory
environment emailing back and forth and
sending documents and sometimes those
those messages are limited to 140
characters and in an email or letter we
often don't we missed the tone of voice
and we missed the body language
completely sometimes you can pick up on
tone of voice today use caps what was
their word choice there are a number of
things to help you there but you admit
completely missed the body language an
electronic message and the message that
you meant to be conveyed was not always
conveyed and the emotional response both
yours and theirs might be at odds and so
I would encourage you to look at how
this happens in your laboratory
environment and when a face-to-face
conversation may result in a better
outcome as opposed to just using words
to convey a message so what is this
elusive concept of emotional
intelligence
well dr. spine has written a great
definition in my opinion and it
specified as the emotional and social
skills that collectively establish how
we perceive now remember go back to
plexus we love emotion so how we
perceive those emotions and then how do
we also express ourselves how we develop
and maintain social relationships and
these are relationships both in
the work environment and outside the
work environment and then how we cope
with the challenges and stressors in
life and stress plays a significant part
in how emotional intelligence shows up
and the way we react and I'm going to
I'm going to be doing a breakout session
at knowledge lab in the spring on stress
and its effect on EQ and finally how we
use the emotional information that comes
at us an effective manner to properly
influence people in a meaningful way so
that's our definition of emotional
intelligence well here's another model
so Rueben Baran another highly respected
practitioner in the field has really
given us a very rich very robust model
and much like the body and knowledge
that you use in your in the laboratory
manager space this model has five
domains and those domains are self
perception self expression interpersonal
decision-making and stress management
and then underneath each one of those
domains are three sub scales and these
these 15 sub scales and five domains
give us the complete model for emotional
intelligence one of the researchers in
the field
Steven Stein and I'll provide you with
another resource of his later on the
webinar has added this other dimension
called happiness and essentially he
takes the the sub skills of self regard
optimism self-actualization and
interpersonal relationships and creates
this sort of happiness factor it's how
do I feel and how how satisfied am i
with life he's also developed an
assessment one that I use in much of my
professional practice to measure each
one of these domains and sub scales and
this
it's been validated with rigorous study
and the results are normed against
various population sets and what this
does it gives gives us the ability now
to compare results for one person to
another and as we'll see later on in the
webinar the ability to use the
assessment for selection and promotion
this is not fairly complicated and
rigorous model and so Baca Stein's come
up with another one that really fits
well in workshops and also gives you the
ability to learn a little bit more about
emotional intelligence without having a
complicated model to do so and I use
this model a lot workshops and I'll also
be using it at knowledge lab at the
pre-conference workshop and go into
extensive detail about each one of these
different areas perceiving and managing
so how I perceive my emotions mine and
others how I manage those emotions and
then how I use my my abilities to make
decisions achieve goals and influence
others in a meaningful way as leaders in
the laboratory you're often given the
role of leading change and sometimes
those changes are small and sometimes
they're large and having a good handle
on how you make decisions and achieve
these goals and a role and role others
in the process are vital to identifying
the gaps and building a plan to help you
close those gaps and become better
leaders I'll provide you with a couple
of resources later in the webinar on how
you can introduce your team and yourself
to this model now we've got two
validated normed models that help give
us some ideas of the the kinds of
elements that are that are makeup
emotional intelligence and but what is
these are some things that emotional
intelligence is not it is not cognitive
intelligence it's not IQ
and it's not aptitude it doesn't predict
somebody's vocational interests or even
their personality and it really doesn't
tell about how somebody will achieve
although it can be used as a selection
criteria to determine whether or not
somebody will be successful in certain
environments so now here's what I want
to do I want to put EQ in action so the
work that dr. Stein Baran and others
have done was really focused on
self-assessment me looking at myself
answering a set of questions on how I
perceive myself and my abilities in EQ
there's another set of researchers out
there by the name of their doctors Meir
sallyboyd Caruso and they've created a
set of assessments that really help
people understand how they put EQ into
action and then their personal and
professional lives and so the next set
of slides I'm going to do is I'm going
to show you some facial expressions and
you'll be asked to decide now there'd be
it's a multiple choice questions to be
asked to decide what emotion the person
is exhibiting so be ready to make a
selection for those in groups just get a
consensus and make that selection and
the faster we can get through these the
we can move through this this process
but I really want you to focus on the
person's face understand what the
emotion is and make a selection so
here's the first one this individuals
showing fear interest surprise or
compassion
you'll see a resource in a moment there
I'm going to run through three facial
expressions but there's a there's a
website and I'll give you the web
address on this website and there's 21
facial expressions that you can run
through with your team or individually
and again it's just the tool to help you
get better at understanding what
somebody might be conveying to you with
body language so we ready to close this
poll all right we have a lot of very
smart people on the line you're correct
it is surprise so again if you go to the
website and just see it down there at
the bottom greater good Berkeley dot I
can't read that on my slide that but you
can you can read this this web link here
and go to that web link and again
there's 21 of these we're going to go
through two more of them so here the the
eyebrows are raised in the the
individual opens his mouth and drops his
job so that is surprise here's another
one is this sadness shame disgust or
contempt
I hope I didn't pick out all the easy
ones for everybody in the group
Cape pulls closed here the results
alright so now we're this one might have
been a little more difficult for people
so we've got contempt as the number one
choice and disgust is the next choice so
let's see what was contempt well these
aren't easy and you know and we deal
with people every single day and we look
at their facial expressions and we make
judgments and reactions based on these
these body language indicators and
sometimes we get those indicators wrong
and when we make a reaction or a
judgment on that and reflect that back
to the individual sometimes things
escalate out of control so let's try one
more this facial expression desire
embarrassment flirtatiousness or love
this one might be too easy everybody in
the room got this one right again I'd
encourage you to go to the website and
and take a look at all 21 of these
facial expressions and and run through
that with your team it's just a big just
a great exercise and just understanding
how you see things and how they see
things so coming up with the poll
results majority show for Taoiseach
sness which is actually correct but
again still we see that there are those
that that miss the indicators and it's
kind of crazy we receive facial
expressions every day and sometimes we
don't pick these up one of the things I
like to do in my workshops is to
actually get people to physically do the
expression shown on the slide on their
own face and when they do that you might
try this if you're sitting in a
conference room or even by yourself try
that and you actually be able to then
begin to feel what that expression is
and more often than not you'll get the
answer correct
thank you again for your participation
so why does all this EQ stuff really
matter right and and how could it impact
the efficiency of production of a
laboratory well I don't have any studies
that directly relate to the lab I will
show you two longitudinal studies using
EQ that resulted in significant
performance improvement and cost savings
and then we can draw some parallels to
really any environment especially the
laboratory environment so here's the
first one the the Air Force was seeing a
significant dropout rate 82% of the
people that entered there pair rescued
jumped school did not graduate this was
not only a huge monetary cost because on
the school's expensive they moved people
across the country and located at the
side of the school
so there's costs associated to do that
but then you have the the added cost of
having the individual fail and that's
not good for morale so they they
undertook a study dr. Stein and others
using the EQI assessment and a rigorous
process and they looked at successful
and unsuccessful candidates and what
they found was that the candidates with
these five listed subscales flexibility
optimism self regard happiness and
reality testing those that were high in
those subscales were more likely to
graduate than those that were low in
those subscales they subsequently
changed the way they were selecting
candidates for pair rescue jump school
and those changes saved about a hundred
ninety million dollars a year in
training costs because there they
increased the the success rate they also
had similar results although not nearly
from a dollar perspective they had
similar results
when they used EQ to select recruiters
they were having a lot of recruiters
that would fail of men and women they
would select them they were great
candidates they put them in these
locales to to work with high school
students to recruit them into the
military and they'd have high failure
rates they went back to did the same
thing took a look at what EQ scales and
they were different EQ scales than these
and they began selecting recruiters
based on emotional intelligence and
again they're the success rate of
recruiters went up and the number of
recruiters that failed to meet goal went
down here's another one from a sales
organization American Express has been
using EQ for a number of years and in
their pilot study they took a group of
financial advisers sent them through
some EQ training and provided in some
ongoing coaching on EQ and they
increased their sales revenue by 18
percent more than the control group
which had no EQ training at all they
also took a group of managers and gave
just the managers EQ training and
compared that against another group of
managers that got no training and they
saw an 11 percent increase in revenue
just just because the manager receives
some emotional intelligence training and
coaching and so these are just two
examples three examples I guess - for
the Air Force that I showed you but use
an EQ for selection and then the other
one using EQ for performance improvement
and where emotional intelligence of the
individual was enhanced and productivity
and cost savings followed so many labs
have roles very similar to this where
individuals market and sell services to
other hospitals and clinics and your
outreach programs and my question to you
is how would a Q training
and or using selection impact your lab
and then how could you use EQ and
developing leadership similar to what
American Express did with their with
their regional managers so I promised a
few tools we've seen we've really seen
two tools already seeing plutchik suil
that's a tool to help sort of put a name
on an emotion we looked at the the
facial expressions tool that's another
one that helps us you know sort of
physically understand how I can use
emotional intelligence and develop a
hard skill set of understanding people's
facial expressions now here are two more
tools I'd like to introduce you to the
first one comes from mark bracket and
this will be the mnemonic and the
mnemonic will spell out the word ruler
mark bracket is a he's a researcher at
the Yale Center for emotional
intelligence does a lot of work in the
school systems with teachers students
administrators etc so the first are and
our mnemonic of ruler is recognized so
now go back again use plutchik squeals
and I had that tool there so recognize
the emotion and feelings and yourself
and others we want to understand the
cause of those emotions am I afraid is
it conflict with my values am i under
stress am I am I am i concerned about
something where does that emotion come
from so understanding the emotion then
we label the emotion so one of the
things that mark Brackett says is if you
can name it you can tame it and the
reason that labeling is so important is
because your emotion comes from sort of
the reptilian side of your brain and in
order for us to put a word or a label on
the emotion I have to use the prefrontal
cortex so I have to use my thinking
brain and the moment I started using my
thinking brain
I cannot more easily control my emotions
then express it there's nothing wrong
with expressing emotion anger joy it
doesn't matter we we should all express
those emotions we just need to do it in
a healthy manner
and not and not do it in a manner that
creates more conflict and lastly
regulate so when we when we know we're
in a in a position and anger is not a
bad thing joy is not always a good thing
and so when we're in a position where we
feel emotion we've labeled it now we
need to be able to regulate it both in
ourselves and others and what I mean by
that is think about how many times and
we've all done this I'm guilty of this
for sure where you've you've seen a
reaction somebody probably a negative
reaction in somebody and you
intentionally push the button again
right so you so you don't help them
regulate it you keep pushing the button
I don't know maybe sometimes it does
feel good I get it but now using this
this mnemonic with ruler the last some
being regulate my emotion and I'm going
to help the other person regulate their
emotion you can watch dr. brackets TEDx
video it's the TEDx Golden Gate
presentation that's easily findable on
on YouTube and definitely well worth
watching as well as some of the research
that he does in EQ well worth reading
so here's another one and this comes
from from a somebody right here in
Rochester Minnesota at the Mayo Clinic
dr. amides sued and he wrote a book
called the Mayo Clinic guide to
stress-free living and I got to see dr.
Sood and I do a presentation a while
back and this is one thing I really took
away from it and not only presented in
workshops I like I try to do this on a
daily basis for myself so it's three
steps so the first step is just about
gratitude so take the first 90 seconds
of your day maybe before you get out of
bed and just think about five things
that you're just grateful for could be
could be that you got a warm hosta to
wake up and it could be you've got
breakfast it could be the year you've
got a job to go to or you're meeting a
friend today all those things are
gratitude so just in 90 seconds and say
and say what am i grateful for the next
thing is novelty so novelty is those
things that are sort of interesting in
life that we may not always notice and
one of the things that dr. Sood says in
his talk is let's say you're eating
lunch with a with a colleague or a
friend and you're focused on your
conversation within but out of the
corner of your eye you see this person
that you went to college with and you
haven't seen him in 20 years
where does your attention go your
attention goes to the novelty to the
person that you haven't seen for 20
years and you want to interact with them
so for 30 seconds every day find a piece
of artwork in the building that you
reside in or stop along the way to and
from work and notice something that
you've never noticed before and spend
some time with it we all have cell phone
cameras or most of us have a camera on
our cell phone and I like to take
pictures and with my camera and document
things along the way during the day and
the last one is and I think this is
there this this one is really important
is to make a commitment take three
minutes before you walk into your house
at the end of a long day and just
understand that you want to be generally
interested in the people with whom
you're going to interact this three
minute respite allows us to get rid of
the stress hormones the cortisol and the
other stress hormones in our body and
get let the oxytocin come in that's
called often referred to as the love
hormone we we excrete this hormone when
we smile when we shake hands and we hug
and so you're just trying to relax
yourself and know you want to be
genuinely interested in the people with
whom you're going to interact with so
there you have it five minutes every day
and you can increase your emotional
intelligence I promise the challenge and
here's the challenge here are two
resources the the book on the right the
EQ edge emotional intelligence and your
success written by dr. Stein really
dives into Rubin Barron's
model for emotional intelligence goes
through every one of the sub scales
every one of the domains provides you
some practical examples to strengthen in
those those areas as well as how low and
high emotional intelligence and each one
of those areas shows up in the work
environment and the other one is the
most limited skilled assessment which is
the that second model that I showed you
from dr. Stein and this workbooks
available and these are available online
so it's 22 bucks for the workbook 20
dollars for the the text but the
workbook is a sort of a self-paced guide
you can go through it take the
assessment there's some work in there
you can do with your team
you can do by yourself and between these
two these two items you can now set
yourself up for 2017 by setting some
goals so here's here's a sheet that I
use so I'll oftentimes in this in a
workshop I'll run people through the the
eisa assessment will get their scores
we'll go through all five of those
domains and then pick out two or three
that they want to take action on and so
when you when you do this you look at
goals I use sort of we've seen SMART
goals so smart being simple motivating
achievable realistic and trackable so
simple so those five things on the eisa
are fairly simple so pick some things
out motivating the goal has to motivate
you if it's motivating somebody else and
you're not motivated to do it and it's
really not going to accomplish the goal
it's really got to be attainable so it's
got to be within your reach
I say relevant or realistic relevant in
that how do you link it to your your job
performance or how do you link it to
something in your personal lives so make
it relevant ie if I if I accomplish this
goal then here's something in my work
life for my professional life or my my
my personal life that's going to get
better and then trackable maybe it's
trackable could be yours using an
assessment trackable could be that
you've you've read a book you've gone
through some exercises you do dr. suits
challenge every day for a month it's
something like that where it's trackable
and your accomplishment
so there you have it that's emotional
intelligence I want to thank you for
participating in the webinar and for
Roche and laberd's for giving me this
this forum and for Mayo Clinic for
hosting me today and reflect back on
using the tools that you have at your
disposal reading about it and
participating in leadership development
so if I could I will open it up for
questions and I you'll see that there
might be a way for people to type
questions in yes indeed and also want to
let the audience know that if you are
interested in the link Calvin mentioned
it will be on your screen shortly and
Thank You Calvin for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is what areas do see
is getting the most leverage from
emotional intelligence probably the the
number one area is really how you see
yourself this whole realm of self
perception and if I if like even if I
can do very well at making decisions I'm
technically capable I can gather
information to make decisions or I Drive
through challenges if I if I don't see
myself in a good light it's very
difficult for me to see others in a good
light and for me to really rise to my
level of capability and and in a lot of
the so in so in the book and that in the
book for dr. Stein what you'll see is in
the back there are some job descriptions
or career fields and
and the top-five emotional intelligence
subscales that they have found to be
relevant for those for those particular
career fields and what you'll find is
almost all of them how I perceive myself
one of those three sub skills and your
self perception are going to be drivers
in those in those professions the next
is how can we apply Eli methods for
group management well I think every
groups going to be a little bit
different so I'm working with a group
right now where we're we've all they've
all taken the emotional intelligence
assessment now we're going to to look at
what this particular group does what
their what their role is within the
broader organization and boil down to
four or five EQ sub scales that are
important for them to get their job done
and how they how they see their role in
the organization and then from that each
person then can now develop their their
plan because now you know what's
relevant so what's relevant to the
organization are might be these five
subscales you might be strong in one two
three or all five of those sub scales
and so now you can put a plan together
to move yourself from where you are to
making a bigger impact on the
organization by just focusing on two or
three out of the 15 sub scale so that's
how I would use it in a group setting
why does personality personality not
contribute to EQ certain personality
types or more extroverted or intuitive
feeling and that could lend to more
social experience allowing them to have
a higher thank you absolutely yeah and
if you look on that one of the skills
sub skills for examples empathy and
clearly different personalities
different people are going to have
different ways that they deal with
people and situations one of the
assessments I use it's very similar to
those like myers-briggs but I use
another one called disc it's a four
quadrant assessment and you can find
people in every one of those quadrants
that can be jerks or that can be highly
effective regardless of how they're
there they come across their personality
so we've all worked with people that are
you know high dominant driver
personalities that again can come off to
be a jerk or could be very compassionate
in the way they drive people and and get
the job done so yes personality plays
part of a role and it and it can be it
can be an influential piece of it but
when you overlay emotional intelligence
on there I still I believe and I in my
work shows that that even people that
have caustic personalities can change by
focusing on these fifteen subscales of
EQ is there any correlation or matrix
relations of the eye with Hofstede
company our structures I am not familiar
with that so I know how to answer the
question all right let's move eyes next
how does intuition coming to play with
emotional intelligence mmm
well you know so an interpersonal domain
there's an intuition could give you
could get a feeling about somebody and
that feeling could be right or wrong you
could make a judgement that may not
totally be factual
but if your intuitive about the way
you're going you can connect with
somebody clearly it's a it's a positive
for emotional intelligence again it's
you know I've seen results from people
that are hardcore scientists that still
have an empathetic reaction that can
still relate to people that don't and
they they have high EQ in some areas
again these these sub skills so when you
take the larger assessment the EQI 2.0
and you get rated in each one of this 15
subscales and five domains you're going
to rate high in some and low in others
and then there's going to be an
interplay and oftentimes we will use a
strength to make up for a weakness so if
I'm if I'm not imp effete ik for example
I might use a different sub scale that
I'm strong in to make people believe I'm
empathetic or to try to be empathetic
what is the secret of the eye for
dealing with different cultures yeah and
then this is not only are we dealing
with different cultures we now we have
four or five generations in the
workforce right so we've got we've got a
global workforce and we have a workforce
that's highly diverse in age and I think
the secret do you really want to know
the secret the secret is talking about
it
the secret is having workshops doing
these assessments putting a plan of
action together talking to people in
different cultures or with different
perspectives and understand where
they're coming from and why they come
from that perspective and and knowing
that it that it's it's it can be a
strength for them in the team and the
Oregon
how can we read people through a
conference call we use remote meetings a
lot that's a tough one and you know that
even in this format so I'm sitting here
in a room I've got four or five other
lab people in the room with me it's so I
can get some reaction from what I'm
saying by watching them but you're right
on a conference call it's very difficult
you miss a piece of it you can get tone
of voice and words but you can't get
body language you can think about my
body language and now we've you know
video is becoming such an easy medium
today with high speed internet access
and I mean here look at this webinar I
mean there's somebody in this thimble
Turkey and there's somebody in in in San
Diego on the call so I mean we can bring
people together from all over the world
we could also do it in video now with
this many people on the call it's
difficult to do with video but for for
smaller engagements I would I use and I
encourage people to use video so you get
all of those pieces in that in that
wheel to fill out the communication gaps
in labs like when we do things faster
than we would like because of deadlines
do cause team and personnel as a manager
how can I best knowledge this pain
without removing it I can't change the
deadline I think you keyed in on the
right word there and that's
acknowledgement in coaching it's not
about it's not about necessarily
changing a feeling or but everybody
wants to be acknowledged
so acknowledge that there are feelings
acknowledged that people are under
stress and and and then just work with
them to get around it again I mean
stress is a big piece of emotional
intelligence what happens in our
is that when you're under stress all
those good things that you do as a ruler
and looking at people's facial
expression and count to 10 and biting
your tongue and you know and all those
things when you're stressed they all go
to the wayside and we become we have
these default reactions and and so again
it a lot of it is helping people
understand how they can strengthen those
those places where they're not so strong
I hate to use the word weak but
strengthen those places where they're
not so strong and then adapt those other
places where they have strengths and
call on those strengths when they need
them body language is 55% of
communication but the study was done in
1971 do you think it has changed
especially with so much digital
communication happening it may be and I
again I don't want to I don't want to
overplay the the work that Mehrabian did
on on body language and what he did was
he he gave people a word and he asked
him for a reaction and there was some
it's it's um there's a lot that goes
into it but think about think about your
communication when you're texting
somebody or when you're writing an email
and how often the actual message got
lost I mean you can transmit numbers and
and sometimes concepts but until you're
having a conversation with somebody and
really face-to-face I think just one of
the earlier callers said haven't you
know Ron conference calls a lot but we
don't get we don't we're not looking at
people you can't see if people are
rolling their eyes on a conference call
and you can't see if people are doing
other things when you're on a conference
call and I mean I there's a possibility
that yeah if the study was done in 71
but we still communicate we still have
these these mediums of communication
that doesn't mean you can't get
information out of a text book or I
can't read a news article in a newspaper
and glean from a
from that strictly by reading text but
in the business world a lot of what we
interact with and communicate with is
not just about communicating facts
there's a lot of feeling emotion opinion
other things that are in there that
change the dynamic and understanding
somebody's body language and seeing it
is a is a piece of the piece of the pie
how do you start a program for emotional
intelligence in an organization-wide
looked at you know how it fits into your
overall training and it's not just about
taking an assessment and saying okay
great and then putting it on the Shelf I
think what you do is you you look at
where you want to go what you're trying
to do within the organization are there
you know where do you see the pain
points what's working great in an
organization I mean so you might have
some things that are just working
excellent and key off of those but I'd
really go into and say what is it that
you want to accomplish and then look at
all the tools and resources that are
available to you and and which ones that
you then believe will make the biggest
impact on you and your team are there
any other resources you would recommend
for leadership development yeah I use a
I use a resource a lot with clients and
it comes out of corn Ferry so they're a
very large human capital development
company all over the world it's called
for your improvement FYI and I've got
that I think the fifth or sixth version
of it but I can't remember but the
there's like 67 leadership competencies
identified within that document and so
within there they'll know for example
delegating is a leadership skill that
we need to develop everybody needs to
have some you're in a leadership role
you need to delegate to people so if you
look at delegate and the FYI it tells
you somebody that's strong the
delegation somebody that's weak and
delegation here's some things you can do
to get better a delegation and then it
gives you a list of resources Harvard
Business Review articles books other
things that you can do to read and
educate yourself on what delegating is
has strengthened that that leadership
set again there's 67 of these leadership
competencies identified in there and
they are they're just great to use and
to help you in the plan and again I use
those when I develop these when I put
these leadership development plans
together with people I'll use the these
companies the competencies that come out
of the for your improvement EQ and then
some other resources and put together a
robust plan for moving people forward
great I would like to once again thank
Calvin for joining us today and leading
us in this discussion it is important to
consider emotional intelligence as you
make plans to move into 2017
and speaking of 2017 don't forget to
join us for our next installment of the
lab leaders webinar series on January
4th 2017 where we will discuss a new
year's resolution become a better
antibiotic steward visit lab leaders
comm for more information thank you
thank you
you